[Music]  but first we have to speak as one United  group who's he  let the binge-watching begin orange is  the new black kicks off their fifth  season on Netflix today  I've done so many incredible projects  over the past couple of years and but  there's something about or different  advice the emmy-winning dramedy will use  all 13 episodes to cover just three days  during a prison ride we did not basic  humanity the show's two-time Emmy winner  Puzo aduba welcomed the challenge and  the storyline my I can tell you there's  a change of power power switches hands  and the stars aren't giving up any more  spoilers excellent idea  well I can certainly tell you all kinds  of things but um you know I don't want  anybody to break my legs in the bathroom  I'd probably expect too much already  [Music]  you